secure big announcements on new coved
restrictions yesterday
uh different leaders of different
nations have gone
in different directions do you think
boris johnson went far enough
yeah there are obviously different rules
now in england scotland and wales and
one of my criticisms of the prime
minister is that he hasn't held the four
nations
um together barely had meetings with the
leaders in
the devolved administrations and it
would be far better if there's one set
of rules across the whole of the united
kingdom
and just in terms of the other issue
which is if we are living with
restrictions for longer
the furlough scheme you want more
support for people
if they can't get back to work as the
government is introducing new
health restrictions it's phasing out
economic support
businesses now as the result of these
new restrictions
are going to be put under huge strain
and you owe it to them to put a support
mechanism in place and the government
really should have done that yesterday
let's move on to your speech yesterday
you talked about the prime minister's
character
in your speech you said of boris johnson
that while he was writing flippant
columns about bendy bananas
i was defending victims and prosecuting
terrorists while he was being sacked by
a newspaper for making up quotes
i was fighting for justice and the rule
of law that they're quite
personal attacks you didn't used to make
such
personal attacks and what's changed i'm
frustrated
that just when our nation needs
leadership
we've got serial incompetence and it
really matters and you've said that a
number of times but it
felt like quite a personal attack do you
personally quite dislike him
well look i don't choose the um
opponent i'm up against here i'm asking
you how you personally feel about him
not about
his performance but do you dislike him
because it feels to me like you just
like well
character matters at a time like this
people looking to the prime minister
um and they they absolutely need the
reassurance
that he and the government are able to
do what's necessary
to ensure the infection rate goes down
and to do what's necessary to avoid mass
unemployment
so at this time above all else character
matters in your speech esther you said
he's just not up to the job
so you do think he's a bad leader the
prime minister and the government
collectively
um are guilty in my view of serial
incompetence
there have been 12 u-turns now i'm quite
prepared to accept
that a government will make mistakes in
a pandemic like this and one or two
u-turns
are probably a sign of a government
listening and then changing but when
you've got
12 in a row the only conclusion is
serial incompetent and
just in that speech you talked
about wilson you talked about blair you
talked about atlea you didn't even
mention
jeremy corbyn you did not even mention
him no name check at all
are you airbrushing him out of the
labour party the point i was making
in my speech the point i was making my
speech is that labour has only had
three election winners in the last 75
years
and i want to be the fourth but the fact
that you didn't mention him
suggests to me that you think he's a
drag on your success
i was making a different point the point
was
that we can have all the ideas
all the aspirations you know we can see
that better society we want to be but if
we don't
um absolutely focus on what's necessary
to win an election
we will never ever get to do what we
came into politics to do which to
change the country for the better why
didn't you mention him though
because i was focusing on recognizing
the scale of the defeat
recognizing we need to change and listen
and being
unrelentingly focused on the seriousness
of women
and recognize he was a bad leader for
labour i was recognizing
that we need to get from where we are
now to winning the next
generation one good thing to say about
him in your speech well
i mentioned the three labour leaders
who've won elections
so let's focus on winning and scotland
you've got a clear strategy when it
comes to boris johnson the conservatives
but what about the snp
you will never win an election if you
can't win
scotland and go back to labour's winners
not since
1955 you'll know this what i'm about to
say
has the labour party formed a government
with less than
40 seats in scotland how many seats do
you have in scotland now
well look i'll be perfectly open about
this
there's no route back for labor that
doesn't run through
scotland how many seats why are we in
scotland it was because
well we've got one and what do you offer
scottish people that might get you
another 39 seats
will you rule out an independence
referendum as boris johnson's done
clearly what i was discussing last week
in scotland with scottish labour was
the importance of rebuilding the economy
in scotland what's your position do you
rule out
another referendum in scotland we will
be making the argument going into that
election next may
that this is not the time for another
divisive independence referendum
there are other priorities do you see
this as we talked about when it came to
brexit as a matter that should have been
settled for a generation not having
another
referendum in scotland another divisive
referendum is i think about the last
thing
that we need in january you said if the
snp won a majority in the hollywood
election they would have
a mandate for that for a second
referendum
i accept this is a question for scotland
do you stand by that principle i'm not
asking you hypotheticals about what
happens in may
do you stand by the principle of what
you said in january
i understand the desire
of many people in scotland have
decisions about them made closer
to them and that is a question for
scotland
i'm asking you about the principle an
snp majority gives them
a mandate for a referendum in january
you said
that you would accept it's a question
for scotland if the snp win
that majority do you in principle stand
by what you say in january or do you
want to move away from that
well we're going into um an election in
may where we will all set out our
position
labour party position but what happened
what you said in january what happens
beyond that is hypothetical and
um you're dodging the question
in politics people say with great
certainty what's going to happen who's
going to win what they're going to do
what's going to happen i'm asking you
whether you stand by what you said in
january when you said they would have a
mandate
for that i accept this is a question for
scotland if they win a majority do you
stand by that
well these issues are questions um for
scotland i do stand
um by that i'm setting out the argument
that we the labour party scottish labour
will be making between now next may okay
thank you very much